no what no it's um you said you said
mark what whatever i thought you're
going to bring up mark wiens
no but i've i uh i saw your profile
picture changed dude like that are you
back into
mark wiens or what's that no no no no no
no no no no
i uh let me pull this up
uh so i i um i knew
he's been i've known that he's made
videos for like ever
and uh uh
he did a podcast with someone and it
featured some old footage of him
okay and i was and i thought yo that
mark wiens
is a very different mark wiens and i
want to show you this mark wiens
yeah show me i could not i'm like this
is not the same guy
okay who is this guy i was blown the
[ __ ] away
play or yeah wait playoff because we
gotta get oh no this is yeah no no we
can ride this out okay
okay yeah yeah okay wait is this the
scene's good and everything
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
first of all this music this is from
2009 11 years ago
what what
so this is mark wiens i'm about to try
some durian here in malacca
malaysia i'm going to eat some all right
he is higher than god bro what he is
he's also he looks like he's in the
[ __ ] sway house dude dude
he he looks like he's like a tick tock
[ __ ] boy dude he's a he's a complete
[ __ ] boy it's like a dude and all the
comments are like thirst it's like oh my
god mark
he's got he's kind of [ __ ] hot dude
no it's like
it's like you see this and you're like
oh how did he what happened to him
mark was [ __ ] mark was [ __ ] man mark
was definitely definitely dude oh my god
he probably started this whole thing
because he was in [ __ ]
you know uh coping yang for the of the
half moon party or whatever oh yeah
yeah and then he was just boys he's just
hiding
he was like yeah it's like he drank a
couple shroom shakes and he's like
we should videotape this dude just wait
we've got a durian i'm going to show you
guys how to eat it i love those sounds
basically you just want to kind of open
it up it's pretty sharp
oh mark yes split it mark
split it open mark there it is right
there
dude the jewelry and everything he's
like wearing rings
yeah yeah so lately dude he like eats a
[ __ ] ton of it and he's not all weird
and exaggerated about it like he just
like bites into it and then like
wait for this part he sounds normal hmm
surprisingly i kind of like it
[Music]
oh my god who's that
the highest [ __ ] ever yeah i know you're
looking at that you're like mark
you scound what are you doing mark what
are you doing everybody doing work
probably about eight chunks of durian i
thought the durian was pretty good at
first and it actually was but
the more i ate it the more you can kind
of you can kind of see a little mark in
there there's no
you can see a little weenie in there you
don't see the weenie just
just this one you see the weenie it just
hasn't like fully burst nah just just
wait for this one though
this one right here this is mark wiens
with migrationalengine.com
it's on the website i got the blog which
i'll constantly be adding to
and i also got the gallery
which includes all kinds of pictures
from all types of excursions
uh i will constantly be upgrading adding
to
creating just wait just wait but anyway
have a look
keep coming back and it's mark wiens
migrationology.com
[Applause]
yeah i'm out i just dude
his voice kills me yeah yeah it's
mark wiens at migrationology.com
like he's such a [ __ ] tool
yeah i'm about to [ __ ] up some durian
right now [ __ ] with my
ho yeah i [ __ ]
i found this girl down at the beach and
i'm gonna [ __ ] her brains out
you know after i eat this durian
we're going to eat durian and [ __ ]
like okay
dude the inner cut of him just eating
this [ __ ] and like spitting it out like
with the red eyes just like putting the
camera all the way up to it oh man
so now we got to fast forward to a
current to a recent video oh bro
so you can see what he's like dog it's
it's yo it's mark wiens
you can't even just this first line let
me play it again while i queue this
up about to feed this [ __ ] my street
meat wins with migrationality.com
our means this is mark wiens with
migrationology.com about to get my
[ __ ] dick sucked after
hey wait go back go back go back dude
that first video
oh man flow oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
no no bro that's what i'm going for now
let me let me let me let me switch this
over you're not even ready you're not
even ready for [ __ ] long hair mark
wayne's bro oh my god dude yeah
that's what i'm going for yeah our
listen wait wait for our boy to be
backwards headed though hold on let me
skip to the let me just get
where's he at where's my guy there he is
where's my guy
grunge bro brushing a beer tower
probably
play it play it but also a little bit
tangy
and you can also taste a little bit of
peanut um because it's sort of mixed in
but it's definitely a refreshing drink
so now he's like made the transition
i honestly feel like and i don't want to
speculate on his life and like if you
watch this don't like don't go [ __ ] off
his comments and [ __ ] just leave mark be
but i feel like maybe you know cause
he's
he's not actually that old he's like a
few years older than us
okay so i think that video of him like
all like stoned and [ __ ] i think he was
like 23.
yeah yeah yeah i mean that makes sense
right so
but i think like he because now he's
like he's pretty religious i think
so i i feel that he used to get really
[ __ ] up and then
i don't know maybe maybe found faith
and then now that's kind of what maybe
inspired him to be a little bit less
more like
yeah i'm about to get my [ __ ] dick
sucked before eating this durian
mark wiens with migrationology.com um
you know what's
you know what's the best post post [ __ ]
snack
durian me and this broad are gonna
[ __ ] up this durian split it open like i
just split her open
wait go so go to a recent video now i
want to see him dog i gotta i gotta get
reminded of his
oh man with mark wiens here jeans here
oh it feels like a wiggling a wiggling
hot dog in your mom
are you gonna eat it yes this is what's
for lunch this is what's for lunch today
he's such a goober now oh my gosh
it's wild the transition to goober is
crazy
you think it's the same same girl same
woman no it's not
bro so his wife's name now is a ying and
i was laughing because
there's a comment on the [ __ ] boy video
they're like that is not yang
oh this is great this is great how did
you find that
i mean it was like crazy yeah he just he
did uh he did a podcast episode it was
like kind of like an interview and then
they featured a clip
of him with the long hair and he's like
i'm in malacca
malaysia i'm like who is that fool
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] elena's like what
video was that i was like close your
eyes
bro yeah yeah yeah exactly i'm out here
in malacca malaysia
getting my dick sucked and eating durian
[Laughter]
getting my [ __ ] sucked off this place
rules